the World Health Organization has
praised China's attempts to contain the
coronavirus the country was quick to
seal off who Bay province where the
outbreak began closing factories and
banning travel and the impact is clear
this shows the daily new cases in who
base since the beginning the numbers
that were once in the thousands are now
in the hundreds and the strict
quarantine measures have stopped the
virus spreading to the rest of China
numbers there are comparatively low but
the virus did spread abroad slowly at
first but now as this line shows the
growth in daily cases is much larger
outside China that comparison is even
clearer when shown as a proportion of
new cases over the last three weeks
China makes up a dwindling share of the
total in Europe the main focus is Italy
which has at least eight times the
number of cases of any other EU country
and a fatality rate of 3.2 percent well
above the global average of one percent
one reason could be that almost a
quarter of Italy's population is aged
over 65 and the elderly are of course at
the highest risk of serious disease
researchers at Imperial College London
think under reporting of mild cases
could also be a factor officially there
are just over 2,500 cases but the real
number could be between 50,000 and
100,000 because so many people have mild
symptoms and taking that into account
would bring the fatality rate down Italy
has though exported the virus to a
number of countries including Spain
where as of lunchtime today at least 18
or is 198 cases had traveled to Italy 18
of Sweden's 35 cases can be traced to
the country and at least 22 of the uk's
87 cases were imported from there the
outbreak in the UK is several weeks
behind
Italy's but we do now have
person-to-person spread and the concern
is we may soon have an epidemic here